bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport numéro 35 allez c'est parti pour
un nouveau tour de l'actus sport du
département en 26 minutes nous vous
ferons découvrir dans cette édition les
mini z c'est bolide à l'échelle 18e à
quelques jours de la finale de la Coupe
du Monde accueilli par véizi et pour la
première fois depuis 1996 les moins de
18 ans de plaisir particip au
championnat de France de handball ils
font mieux que se défendre d'ailleurs et
sont pour l'instant deuxè de leur poule
rencontre à suivre immersion aussi à
suivre au sein du team Shahid chînet ce
club de boxe thaïlandaise est une
pépinière à champion nous avons voulu
comprendre les raisons de ce succès
évidemment enfin d'émission tous les
résultats du weekend mes places tout
d'abord au cyclissement du
sport j'ai été squeezé par le jingle
mais mais c'est pas grave place donc au
cyclisme and dis sport et à la création
de la section hand bike du Vélo Club
d'lancours 50 ans yeline ce club
d'ailleurs qui continue de se structurer
et pour en parler évidemment le
président Thierry Fabre et le nouveau
responsable de la section on bike Erric
Castali bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir
ce projet comment est-il né d'une
section on bike c'est plutôt peu commun
dans dans les parages en yeline en tout
cas il vient à l'origine il vient d'une
amitié d'une amitié entre Éric et
moi-même donc euh Eric était un sportif
et toujours un sportif accompli c'était
un cycliste un vtétiste un vété
organisateur de et soutient de la
revancheard à mes côtés donc suite à son
accident
et il est revenu parmi nous heureusement
puisqu'il était blessé gravement il a eu
un courage exceptionnel il a toujours fa
voulu faire du sport il y avait aucune
structure pour pouvoir l'accueillir avec
ses projets et son onbike et nous on
s'est dit ben on se lance il faut aider
les les handicapés sportifs à intégrer
une cellule de gens valides pour qu'il a
une osmose entre nous pour le sport tout
simplement Éric à partir de quand vous
avez commencé à pratiquer le le handbike
on va dire que moi à partir du moment où
j'étais en réa ma seul objectif mon seul
objectif pour vivre é de continuer le
sport donc je me suis accroché à ça et 2
ans après voilà j'ai contacté Thierry
j'ai dit j'ai un projet il faut qu'on
fasse du sport ensemble je veux
continuer à tourner les roues donc ti
m'a accepté dans le projet et
aujourd'hui maintenant on arrive à tous
les deux à créer cette section et à
pouvoir emmener des gens avec nous sur
des sections de bac vous me disiez quand
on préparait l'émission vous étiez
cycliste valide quand vous prépareiez
notamment la revanchard la
traditionnelle course organisée par le
club au mois de juin comment on se remet
en selle si j'ose dire après un accident
comme le vôtre ah c'est très difficile
il faut j' très bien encadré avec
l'hôpital de Garche et de Rambouillet
j'ai fait énormément 2 ans de kiné et
après c'est énormément de musculation
beaucoup de sport puis un gros moral et
et puis de voir encore ce weekend
chry mouiller le maillot pour organiser
des courses cy cross ce weekend qui
était encore une fois très populaire je
crois et du coup par rapport à à cet
entraînement spécifique parce que l'bac
bah la position est différente sur sur
la selle comment comment on travaille
l'entraînement on travaille beaucoup les
bras parce que on travaille plus les
jambes on pe plus travailler les jambes
donc on fait énormément de musculation
et beaucoup de sorties en fauteuil pour
obtenir l'endurance et beaucoup de
pédalage avec les bras en raison deux
entraînements par par semaine on va
essayer d'empanter quand les beaux jours
vont arriver mais c'est beaucoup
d'entraînement il y a une technique
particulière c'est juste une rotation
des bras c'est ça c'est une technique un
peu particulière c'est une rotation des
bras et on dirige le vélo avec les bras
mais c'est beaucoup de de technique on
passait des endroits où on passe en vélo
et là on est un peu plus large on fait
90 cm de large donc c'est une autre
approche du vélo il y a déjà des
demandes sur lesin justement pour
pratiquer le onbike Thierry ou nous on a
fait un grâce à er on a fait un recr
recrutement de de qure sportifs dont un
pour imaginer un peu ce que ça
représente l'bike nous on a une spé bike
été mais il y en a un collègue qui fait
long by route il nous a illustré un peu
une descente de Loir inimaginable à 100
àheure d'accord voilà donc je pense que
c'est c'est impressionnant et donc c'est
vraiment des sportifs et nous en plus
euh comme on on on l'exposa ensemble
tout à l'heure on a on féère nos jeunes
pour des actes de citoyenneté parce
qu'on vient d'ouvrir une section vélo
jeune à partir de 9 ans et samedi c'est
l'ouverture officielle du premier
entraînement hbag VTT et nos gamins avec
Eric ça doit être un événement important
pour le nouveau responsable justement la
concrétisation d'un projet puis d'une
amitié aussi qui était derrière tout
cela non c'est un oui c'est un un réel
bonheur de pouvoir partager ça avec des
enfants et et puis créer la section
c'est un une discipline quiit pas du
tout en Europe on a orté le premier
roundb du canadacord et là on est en
train de développer tout doucement avec
une société qui s'appelle m presto de
ces hand B qui viennent du Canada mais
comme souvent dans les disciplines de
handisport je pense au hand fauteuil
notamment ou au tennis fauteuil
l'équipement est assez cher c'est aussi
le cas là en handbike Thierry oui oui en
plus le projet d'Eric qui qui faitdre
c'est s'ouvrir aux autres ça veut dire
que trouver des partenaires financiers
qui nous aideraient à acheter des
handbike pour que éc puisse porter et
prêcher la bonne parole des sportifs
comme lui pour qu' qu'on puisse faire
découvrir au aux sportif handicapés leur
une bike et leur mettre à disposition
des vélos qui sont chers c'est ça notre
but c'est le but qu'on puisse bah
fédérer autour de d'une découverte du
sport ne pas les laisser de côté ouais
parce que on va dire que à peu près le
prix moyen pour unbike de compétition
vous me le disiez c'était à peu près
5000 € donc c'est vrai que c'est un
investissement important pour un un
jeune sportif en tout cas c'est un
investissement assez important 5000 €
c'est ça ça représente une certaine
somme sachant qu' en plus pour se
déplacer on a besoin d' hôel
traditionnel qui coûte à peu près aussi
5000 € donc pour pouvoir pratiquer bah
faut une enveloppe de 10000 €. et alors
pour le nouveau responsable de la
section unbike quels sont les objectifs
sportifs peut-être à moyen terme moi les
objectifs c'est qu'on va organiser une
sortie avec les enfants au mois de juin
on va faire les bords de Loire enbac et
VTT et l'année prochaine c'est de relier
le lac lément à Montpellier sur une
semaine après il y a tout plein de
petites épreuves comme ça de sportif
mais des petits challenges en fin de
comp challenges le challenge et pouvoir
faire du sport et amener d'autres
handicapés avec moi à pratiquer le sport
tiierry en tant que président je sais
que vous êtes au four et au moulin en ce
moment avec le nouveau vélodrome il y a
l'activité du club s'étend beaucoup vous
comptez profiter justement des
installations du vélodrome de 50 anine
pour cette section ou pas oui avant de
répondre à C question là il oublié
quelque chose d'important la revancheard
c'est la maison mère du VC Sky et pu de
satin en y dans les organisations et ben
pour la première fois on va faire une
démoration démonstration on bike avant
le départ voilà donc ça sera aussi un
événement important c'est un événement
important je pense que vous allez nous
soutenir comme d'habitude et pour la
piste alors il y a effectivement notre
marine Isabelle gatron ancienne
DTN était on a eu une réunion jeudi soir
donc jeudi soir elle a de nouveau
ressigné sa licence en qualité de cadre
technique ouais Isabelle gatron faut le
rappeler hein c'est la marine du club et
elle s'occupe de la section piste voilà
officiellement donc elle prend la
section piste depuis
depuis
jeudi je vais pas en dire plus vous
gardez encore quelques secrets quelques
secrets on a un créneau le dossier est
en mains d'Isabelle il des belles choses
ce projet pour nous mais tout simplement
elle a le dossier dans les mains et
quand on a été C fois championne de
France de vitesse sur piste et DTN je
pense que ça veut tout dire ouais tout à
fait juste pour rappeler la date
peut-être vous l'avez déjà pour la
prochaine rchard si on veut voir
justement cette démonstration de 30 juin
2014 15 ans les 15 15 ans de la revch
15s ce qu'il faut signaler c'est que le
handb tout terrain n'existait pas en
France ni en Europe donc on est vraiment
la première sction à créé le handb tout
chemin très bien donc vous inaugurez
complètement ENF de ces derniers mois ça
inaugure beaucoup en tout cas du vé du
Vélo Club pardon enc de 550 anine on
suivra tout ça évidemment lors de des
prochaines manifestations merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'être passés sur le set
sport et à bientôt sur la piste
peut-être alors sans transition place à
la box thaille le club de box
thaïlandaise du chînet est une une
pépinière à champion créé en 2009 le
team Shahid a connu une progression
fulgurante et compte désormais n serrant
plusieurs champions de France qui
bénéficie du premier centre de
perfectionnement espoir du pays nous
avons rencontré cette génération doré
avec Hod
moan l'été dernier Guillaume babouin
participe à son 3è camp d'entraînement
en Thaïlande vainqueur par chaos sur ce
high kick de son premier combat au
royaume de Siam l'étudiant de 20 ans a
pu prolonger son rêve avec 10 victoires
en 12 combats il est considéré comme
l'un des espoirs du français double
champion de France junior amateur dans
deux catégories différentes cette
ancienne ceinture noire de karaté monte
cette saison chez les amateurs élite
mais ce n'est en rien comparable avec
son expérience thaïlandaise ici tu as
ton
travail tu as ton travail tu te lèves le
matin tu viens le soir tu t'entraînes
là-bas c'est c'est entre guillemets ton
travail tu fais que ça de la vie tu te
lèves tu vas boxer tu reviens tu manges
tu dors tu fais la sieste tu retournes à
la boxe de l'autre côté du ring
Alexandre Gard n'a connu la défaite qu'à
une seule reprise en l'espace de 4
saisons à 20 ans il s'est déjà immergé
dans la culture thaïlandaise lors d'un
stage d'entraînement il y a quelques
mois histoire de sentir le parfum du
combat ultime à l'autre bout du monde
c'est un rêve depuis qu'on a commencé à
pratiquer on a un peu de d'appréhension
parce que c'est différent c'est en
France enfin c'est en Thaïlande et mais
bon les Thaïlandais c'est c'est des mecs
qui ont de pied demain comme nous cette
génération doré ne manque pas de talent
à ses côtés lors des derniers champion
France amateur Mohamed Bouar a été sacré
en moins de 63 kg pourtant il y a 4 ans
lors de la création du team Shahid rien
nindiquait ces succès sur le ring le
club commence alors avec seulement deux
sacs de frappe désormais pour se
préparer les ivinois bénéficient du
premier pô espoir en France mise en
place cette saison par Stéphane Geoffrey
mais l'entraînement ne suffit pas il
faut une hygiène de vie d'accord comme
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un sport qui est très fractionné
qui demande énormément de de tonicité et
d'explosivité donc celui qui va fumer un
petit peu qu' a une hygiène qui qui n'a
pas de sommeil qui s'alimente mal
forcément il va revenir au aux sources
et aux valeurs c'estad avoir une une un
équilibre et une hygiène de vie saine
leur prochain combat majeur la Coupe de
France en décembre l'occasion de
concrétiser l'expérience
thaïlandaise
le mini ce weekend à l'occasion de la
finale de la Coupe du Monde de la
discipline véis d'ailleurs on est le
club haute on va dire et pour en parler
les deux organisateurs les deux
principaux organisateurs parce que
j'imagine que vous êtes beaucoup
derrière au fourneau en ce moment David
Duray et Carlos Guerrero bonsoir à tous
les deux je vois que vous êtes venus en
plus pas les mains vides tout d'abord le
concept du Med qu'est-ce que c'est pour
expliquer simplement au
téléspectateursy
une quand on parle de mini déjà on parle
vraiment de modélisme c'est des petites
voitures Radi commmandées à énergie
électrique qui fonctionne juste avec
quatre petits accus qui sont
classiques qui évolue sur des pistes
spécifiques soit mocket soit uréane
c'est un modélisme d'intérieur l'échelle
en 28e donc après sur sur un châssis on
peut habiller le châssis de tout un tas
de carrosseries différentes et tout les
petites voitures de de sport en fait ont
leur petit clone quoi et Carlos comment
le on le pilote ce petit bolil là à
l'échelle 28e et bien tout simplement
avec une une radio bon il y a plusieurs
niveaux de radio là on a le le haut de
gamme la la télécommande de compétition
on va dire un exactement c'est la la la
plus grosse mais c'est une radio en 2 Go
4 donc le
dernier pour être concret juste il y a
j'imagine une touche d'accélérateur
frein c'est ça il y a une molette non
donc on a une gâchette d'accélérateur
frein et ici on a le le volant de la
direction gauche- droite et ces petits
bolid ils ont une pointe de vitesse hors
norme j'imagine une quarantaine de
kilmèh pour les pour les plus gros gros
moteurs en fait voilà ça va dépendre de
tout un tas de de de critères il y a
plusieurs catégories dans la dans la
discipline et chaque catégorie
correspond à un règlement et dans ce
règlement une puissance moteur
différente un moteur différent pour donc
euh ça passe ça passe par des moteurs
qu'on appelle des moteurs 70 tours qui
sont les plus petits on va dire
jusqu'aux euh 33 tours ou 32 tours qui
sont les les plus puissants et là
effectivement cette catégorie là on
atteint des vitesses qui sont qui font
40 environ 40 km/h sur une piste large
de 90 cm donc la la sensation de vitesse
est vraiment réelle je le disais hein
vous allez accueillir dans quelques
jours la finale de la Coupe du Monde de
mini z nous nous sommes rendus au velliz
votre club ce weekend pour voir un peu
comment bah les pilotes qui qui allait y
participer se prépare à cet
événement on enchaîne les tours on teste
des huiles des des pneumatiques des
ressorts des réglages de train avant et
de Pod arrière avec différentes
configurations de moteur on fait toute
une série de tests sur la piste qui y a
juste à côté de nous euh des rodages de
pneumatique j'imagine Carlos que la
préparation doit être très personnalisée
hein chacun fait un peu ses essais à sa
façon chacun part sur son type de
réglage et s'adapte en fait il va régler
la voiture par rapport à son type de
pilotage donc on est tous différents
quoi il y a toujours la partie essai
qu'on qu' la partie de l'ombre on va
dire dans une course mais il y a aussi
peut-être des réglages à faire le jourg
David toujours parce que chaque chaque
piste a ses caractéristiques une piste
va être tantôt rapide tantôt sinueuse
donc chaque piste est spécifique et
comme disait Carlos c'est aussi le le
propre style du du pilotage quoi donc en
fonction du type de la piste et de son
propre style de pilotage on va adapter
certains réglages maintenant il y a des
réglages on va dire plus ou moins type
mais il y a toujours toujours quelque
chose affiner dans le choix du
pneumatique ou des ressorts comme le
disait si bien Denis qu'on a vu dans le
reportage il y a un châssis aussi je
sais que souvent dans ces compétitions
mini il y a un châssis juste pour les
qualifications un peu comme en F1
parfois il y a des réglages Calif et des
réglages
coures on va plus on va plus jouer sur
les accumulateurs peut-être mettre des
accumulateurs plus puissants sur une
qualification et plus endurant sur une
course c'est la seule chose qui parce
que il y a il y a il y a quand même le
règlement qui est assez assez spécifique
assez restreint donc on peut pas trop
sortir de Mar voilà
donc ceci dit c'est possible he il peut
très bien y avoir de de de deux types de
pinonneries qu'on va mettre sur ce
moteur là pour avoir plus de vitesse ou
moins de vitesse en voilà c'est c'est ça
va être au choix du pilote mais mais de
toute façon il va falloir quand même
rester dans dans le règlement quoi et le
Jorg quelle technique de pilotage vous
adoptez tout pour l'attaque on essaie
plus d'avoir des trajectoires arrondies
pour éviter les les sorties de route non
comment ça se passe c'est un compromis
de tout je pense il faut un peu t faut
être agressif tout en ayant une marge il
faut être agressif tout en étant
propre chaque pilote aura aura sa propre
vision aussi de la course et de la
piste personnellement j'ai plus tendance
à à pas
trop aller à l'attaque directement et
vraiment prendre confience prendre
confiance à force de tourner sur la
piste bien connaître les les secteurs
sur lesquels on est à l'aise donc sur
lesquels on peut vraiment attaquer et
les secteurs sur lesquels on serait
moins à l'aise et donc prendre moins de
risque enfin pour revenir sur la la
compétition en elle-même comment ça va
se dérouler il y a 3 jours de
compétition j'imagine ESS qualification
et finale non c'est ça donc ça sera le
le
vendredi matin ça sera les essais libres
ensuite l'après-midi on aura une sorte
de préqualification pour essayer de
ranger un petit peu les groupes ou
niveler un petit peu tout ça voilà
niveler un peu les niveaux et puis après
on passera sur sur la qualification
réelle et après les finales le dimanche
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde il y a
130 pilotes à peu près 13 nationalités
différentes donc c'est vrai que les
meilleurs mondiauxx vont se retrouver à
véis dans quelques jours c'est ça c'est
c'est un beau succès en effet on
accueille environ 50 étrangers quoi donc
presque 45 % des des participants seront
étrangers il y a beaucoup de pays de
l'Europe qui sont présentés mais ceux
qui viennent de plus loin viennent de
Russie du Mexique des États-Unis donc on
a vraiment un beau panel de de continent
représenté quoi c'est bien et donc toute
la journée à chaque fois les T
lespectateurs pourront venir entrer
libre pour admirer un peu les bolid pour
tout le monde entré libre de 8h de 8h à
22h au gymnase Wagner de véis Villa
coublet donc c'est le pour ce c'est le
le le centre sportif Robert Wagner la la
piscine également qui est sur place donc
de 8h à 21h on sera on sera sur place
voilà très bien merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'être passé sur le 78 sport et
puis bon courage et bonne chance
peut-être si vous participez aux
différentes catégories et puis on sera
là pour évidemment voir ce que ça donne
en vrai merci beaucoup merci à vous pour
la première fois depuis 1996 les moins
de 18 ans de plaisir en handball
participent au championnat de France
cette compétition se déroule en deux
phases un mini championnat à 6 jusqu'en
décembre et la phase finale à partir de
janvier et c'est plutôt bien parti hein
pour les plaisirs après les matchs allés
ils sont 2uxè de leur pou rencontrre
avec une avec une équipe où cohésion et
rigueur sont les maîtres
mot c'est peut-être de là qu'ils tirent
leur succès pas un mot plus haut que
l'autre à l'entraînement les regards
sont tous concentrés sur le même
objectif car pour la première fois
depuis 1996 les jeunes de plaisir
évoluent au niveau national après 3
années passées ensemble et pour cette
nouvelle aventure le groupe n'a
quasiment pas changé finalement après de
journées le le seul renfort important
est sur le banc l'entraîneur Alexandre
taer a débarqué d'ivr et a pris les
commandes du train Plaisirois surtout
que SV l'ci entraîneur avait ce groupe
depuis 2 ans 2 ans est là le début et
donc avait vraiment bien construit
l'état de groupe vraiment et la relation
de confiance entre les joueurs et
d'abnégation et donc ça voilà ça c'était
du tout cuit pour moi et c'était une
très bonne chose parce que bien souvent
c'est peut-être ce qu'il y a de plus dur
à mettre en place depuis la première
journée de championnat les plaisiris non
connu la défaite et démontre match après
match du caractère comme face au leader
boulong B en cours on perd buts à la
mi-temps on encaisse le premier but il y
a 9U buts et malgré tout voilà il
continue à m'écouter moi je j'y crois
toujours et et on revient on mène plus 1
à 30 secondes de la fin et finalement on
est un de moins donc on encaisse le
dernier but et on fait match nul donc
c'est une grosse perte chez le premier
en plus CIT à l'extérieur donc ça prouve
que c'est une équipe qui voilà qui
abandonne pas qui qui joue jusqu'au bout
et qui se BAGAR et comme moi
faut pas se sentir irrésistible non plus
faut pas rester dans l'euphorie du jeu
parce que comment s sinon reste jouer et
c'est là le problème c'est pour ça faut
continuer toujours à l'entraînement
rester bien joué la rigueur à la place
d'une saison découverte l'exercice
pourrait se transformer en une aventure
inoubliable mais pour atteindre la
première division du championnat de
France en janvier prochain et faire
partie des 50 meilleures équipes du pays
plaisir va devoir terminer parmi les
trois premiers de sa poule après la
phase allé une deuxè place provisoire le
semble
Plaisirois allez on passe au résultats
du
weekend une fois n'est pas coutume place
au football guillancour a enfin débloqué
son compteur victoire pour le compte de
la 5e journée de promotion d'honneur
leesg accueillé au stade Maurice Baquet
le PEC dans un derby qui sentait le
souffre entre mal classé après une
réunion de crise dans la semaine où les
joueurs de Jud talmo se sont dit leur
vérité les ctinois ont enfin joué
ensemble après avoir ouvert le score en
première période le SGC le sort du match
sur cette longue ouverture côté droit
l'attaquant gu en courtois efface son
défenseur d'un crochet extérieur ça
frappe s'écrase sur la barre
transversale mais le ballon est
finalement poussé au fond desfilets gu
encours s'impose au terme des 90 minutes
2-0 et remonte du coup à la 9e place au
classement il manquait la cohésion de
groupe il manquait aussi un peu d'envie
et de combativité chose qu'on a vraiment
vraiment retrouvé aujourd'hui et puis
l'état d'esprit et puis le groupe on a
retrouvé un groupe par rapport au match
précédent où où c'était vraiment
individuel alors qu'aujourd'hui voilà on
sentait qu'on s'est battu les uns pour
les autres et ça a fait la différence
dans les autres rencontres de Promotion
d'Honneur c'était le weekend des
premières tout simplement trappe s'est
incliné sur la pelouse de Saint-Leu 2-0
et les Trappistes connaissent là leur
première défaite de la saison ils
redescendent du coup à la 3e place à
deux points du leader nanire en football
féminin chez les femmes 7e journée de
Division 2 on suit évidemment Montini
mais qui n'a pas réédité he son carton
face à Dijon il y a 15 jours un 7-0 pour
le rappel les joueus de Jordanie grosses
se sont sévèrement incliné 4-0 sur la
pelouse de Compiegne elle reste 12e et
lanterne rouge de leur groupe en rugby
pour le compte de la 7e journée de
fédéral 3 évidemment plaisir recevait ce
dimanche le dernier nojan le Rotrou au
stade Robert Baran le jeu très offensif
du Prz comme d'habitude et les
multiplication de temps de jeu ont très
vite fait craquer la défense de roir les
joueurs de Philippe Béard en bleu et
jaune sur votre écran IVe la bagatelle
de 5 essais il s'impose finalement 311
et empochche le bonus le bonus offensif
pardon c'est la 5e victoire consécutive
des Plaisirois qui n'ont plus qu'un
point de retard sur le leader Orléan et
une petite image plutôt amusante hein
toujours à plaisir au PRC juste avant la
rencontre de l'équipe Fanon 1h30 plutôt
la réserve plaisiroise a détruit
l'équipe B de nos gens le Rotrou 100 à 7
et vous le voyez hein sur l'image pas
assez de place en fait sur le tableau
d'affichage pour pour mettre le score
100 seulement ça s'est arrêté à
99 toujours rugby 5e journée du
championnat territorial d'honneur le Sky
rugby se déplacé à brtini mais les inois
n'ont pas trop existé défaite 48 à 6 ils
sont toujours derniers de leur Pol le
maintien va vite devenir compliqué à ce
rythme 4e journée de probé tennis de
table etencour n'a laissé aucune chance
à Saint-Denis s'imposant facilement 4
matchs à zéro les joueuses de Fran
Sonier reçoivent ce mardi au Palais des
Sports d'élencours et Chirol pour le
compte de la 5e journée en basket 7e
journée de National uneune féminine
l'entente le chîn et Versailles se
devait de réagir après trois défaites
consécutif dans un duel de mal classé à
Rennes et les ivlinois se sont sont bien
bien reprises avec une victoire
précieuse en Bretagne 67 à 56 les
joueuses de Stéphane Rouy remontent du
coup à la 8e place au classement général
chez les hommes 7e journée de National 3
c'est sur le même rythme le SLV s'est
incliné sur son parquet face à jeun
Villier 73 à 88 même sort pour trappe
défit au Paris- leevallois 64 à 44 en
bal les féminines de Montini après leur
défaite au valdorge la semaine dernière
se sont bien reprises au blanc Ménil en
s'imposant 32 à 23 pour le compte de la
5e journée avec notamment 8 buts de
Gabriel parloè et avec ce succès à
l'extérieur les inimonaines font un bon
classement de 9e à 5e elles sont
désormais donc à 4 points du leader Gani
roll Requet 4e journée de National 2 et
C ne rigole toujours pas pour les chocks
des lcou ils se sont à nouveau inclinés
ce weekend cette fois-ci à Villeneuve
plutôt sèchement d'ailleurs un 13-2 les
joueurs de Benjamin Ferrand restent
dernier de leur poule une dernière info
c'est de la natation vous le savez il y
avait le le meeting national des grands
maîtres organisé à morpas ce weekend la
5e édition c'était en bassin de 25 m un
concours qualificatif d'ailleurs pour
les championnats de France à noté les
bonnes performances des nageurs
cinquantinois à l'image de Yan faskel
qui monte sur le podium sur le trophée
100 m et auréie Berly et Laurence Bill
vainqueur respectif dans leur catégorie
sur le trophée 50 m et pour finir le 78
sport évidemment l'agendin du weekend
tout d'abord on en parlait le mini z la
finale de la Coupe du monde le 8 9 et 10
novembre prochain à véisie Villa coublet
donc au Centre sportif Robert Wagner il
y aura du football aussi 2è tour de la
coupe des Ines ce dimanche 10 novembre
vous pourrez supporter trappe Guill en
cour encore Saint- cirque cou d'envoi
des rencontres à 14h30 et enfin du rugby
6e journée du championnat territorial
d'honneur entre le Sky rugby et le
Sporting Club universitaire de France
cooup d'envoie à 15h c'est la fin de ce
78 sport merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à le
commenter he sur Twitter via le hashtag
tout attaché le 78 sport et non pas à à
lundi prochain mais à mardi pour cause
de jour férier d'ici là excellente
soirée sur TV
fil